HOST: So I'm incredibly
excited to be here today
to introduce Kevin Kwan, the
international bestselling
author of "Crazy Rich Asians"
and "China Rich Girlfriend,"
the first two of an intended
three novels about the schemers
and dreamers in
Asia's upper crust.
So my friends and I were
obsessed with the ridiculously
titled "Crazy Rich Asians"
when we visited Singapore back
in 2013.
And we would just run around
Asia quoting the book,
even though we were
all not so rich Asians.
And we went wild when
Kevin released the sequel
earlier this year.
And I would say that's the
great thing about the book
and the strength of Kevin's
writing-- it doesn't matter
if you weren't raised in
Asia or you didn't grow up
with Thai lady maids, the
writing just sucks you in
and it paints such a vivid
picture of the lifestyle
and his character's mindsets.
Which also explains
why he's been featured
in "Vanity Fair," "The
Atlantic," "The Wall Street
Journal," NPR, among
other media sources,
and that there's now a
movie version in the works
by the same producers
of "Hunger Games."
So with that said,
please join me
in giving a warm Google
welcome to Kevin Kwan who
will be doing a reading from
his book, after which we will
precede to Q&A session,
then take questions
from the audience.
OK, clap.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN KWAN: Hey, thanks for
coming here today on your lunch
break or whatever.
It's just so amazing
to be at Google.
The company that we use every
second of our lives, basically.
So it's really a
thrill to be here
and to see such a
great turnout to come
see me read from my book.
So I guess I should just start
with doing a brief reading.
HOST: Yes.
KEVIN KWAN: I just I'd just kick
start things to get the juices
flowing.
HOST: China Rich Girlfriend.
KEVIN KWAN: And I'm going
to read from "China Rich
Girlfriend," my new novel, which
is the sequel to "Crazy Rich
Asians."
And I'm reading a chapter
I've never read before live.
So if I stumble, if I trip
and fall, you know why.
"London, 8th of September, 2012.
9:00AM, Greenwich Mean Time.
A red Ferrari 458 Italia crashed
through the window of the Jimmy
Choo Shoe Boutique on Sloane
Street sometime between 4:00AM
and 4:30AM last night.
No one witnessed the incident.
Metropolitan Police
reported that two passengers
were taken to Saint
Mary's Paddington
where they're being treated
for serious but non-critical
injuries.
The vehicle's
owner's name was not
released pending
further investigation.
Sarah [? Liar ?],
the London Chronicle.
Beijing Capital International
Airport, September 9, 2012,
7:45PM.
"Wait a minute,
I'm in first class.
Take me to first class."
Edison Cheng said contemptuously
to the flight attendant
escorting him to his seat.
"This is first
class, Mr. Cheng,"
the man in the crispy
navy uniform informed him.
"But where are the cabins,"
Eddie asked, still confused.
"Mr. Cheng, I'm afraid
British Airways does not have
private cabins in first class.
But if you'll allow
me to show you
some of the special
features of your seat--"
"No, no, no.
That's fine."
Eddie tossed his ostrich
leather briefcase onto the seat
like a petulant schoolboy.
"Damn it to hell.
The sacrifices I have to
make for this bank today."
Edison Cheng, the pampered
prince of privative bankers.
Famous in Hong
Kong society pages
for his bon vivant lifestyle,
his dapper wardrobe,
his elegant wife, Fiona,
his photogenic children,
and his superb
lineage-- his mother
is Alexandra Young,
of the Singapore
Youngs-- was unaccustomed
to such inconveniences.
Five hours ago he
had been interrupted
during a luncheon at
the Hong Kong Club,
rushed aboard the company
jet bound for Beijing,
and then hustled on to
this flight to London.
It had been years since he
had suffered the indignity
of flying commercial.
But Mrs. Bao was on
this godforsaken plane,
and Mrs. Bao needed
to be accommodated.
But where exactly was the lady?
Eddie expected to find
her seated nearby,
but the chief parser informed
him there was no such person
by that name in the cabin.
"No, no, she's
supposed to be here.
Can you check the flight
manifest or something?"
Eddie demanded.
Minutes later,
Eddie found himself
being led to row 37, seat E of
the aircraft-- economy class--
where a petite woman
in a white Vicuna
turtleneck and
gray flannel slacks
sat sandwiched between
two passengers.
"Mrs. Bow?
Bao Shou Yen?"
Eddie inquired in Mandarin.
The woman looked up
and smiled wanly.
"Are you Mr. Cheng?"
"Yes, so glad to meet you.
I'm sorry we had to me like
this," Eddie smile in relief.
He had spent the past eight
years managing the Bao family's
offshore accounts.
But they were such
a secretive lot,
he had never met any
of them until today.
Even though she looked
rather tired at the moment,
Bow Shou Yen was
much prettier than he
had imagined with alabaster
skin, large eyes that slanted
upwards at the edges,
and high cheekbones
accentuated by the way she
wore her jet black hair,
pulled into a
tight, low ponytail.
She did not look old enough
to have a son in grad school.
"Why are you seated here?
Was there some mix up?"
Eddie asked urgently.
"No, no.
I always fly economy
class," Mrs. Bao replied.
Eddie couldn't hide
his look of surprise.
Mrs. Bow's husband,
Bao Gowlong, was one
of Beijing's top politicians.
And what's more,
he had inherited
one of China's biggest
pharmaceutical firms.
The Baos weren't just one
of his regular clients,
they were his ultra
high net worth clients.
"Only my son flies first
class," Bao Shou Yen
explained, catching
Eddie's luck.
"Carlton can eat all of
the fancy Western food.
And being a student
under so much pressure,
he needs all the
rest he can get.
But for me it's not worth it.
I don't touch airplane food.
And I can never sleep on
these long flights anyway."
Eddie had to resist his
urge to roll his eyes.
Typical mainlanders.
They lavished every penny
on their little emperor
and suffered in silence.
Well, look where that got them.
23-year-old Carlton
Bao was supposed
to be at Cambridge finishing
his master's dissertation,
but had instead spent
the previous evening
doing his best Prince
Harry impersonation,
running up a 38,000 pound bar
tab at half a dozen London
night spots, wrecking
his brand new Ferrari,
destroying public property, and
almost getting himself killed.
And that wasn't even
the worst of it.
The worst of it, Eddie had
been explicitly instructed
not to reveal to Bao Shou Yen.
Eddie faced a conundrum.
He urgently needed to go
over the plans with Mrs. Bao,
but he would sooner
endure a colonoscopy
than spend the next 11
hours slumming it in coach.
God in heaven, what if
someone recognized him?
A picture of Edison Cheng
crammed into an economy class
seat will go viral
within seconds.
Yet Eddie begrudgingly realized
that it would be unseemly
for one of his bank's
most important clients
to remain here in steerage
while he was up front,
stretched out on a
flat bed recliner,
sipping 20-year-old cognac.
He eyed the spiky haired youth
slouching dangerously close
to Mrs. Bao on one side,
and the elderly woman
clipping her nails in
the air sickness bag
on her other side, a
solution springing to mind.
Lowering his voice, Eddie said.
"Mrs. Bow, I would of
course be happy to join you
in this cabin, but there
are some highly confidential
matters we need to discuss.
Would you allow me to arrange
a seat for you up front?"
"Well, I suppose if
the bank insists,"
Bao Shou Yen replied
a little hesitantly.
After takeoff when
aperitifs had been served
and they were both
comfortably ensconced
in the sumptuous pod-like
seats facing each other,
Eddie wasted no time
updating his client.
"Mrs. Bao, I was in contact with
London just before boarding.
Your son has been stabilized.
The surgery to repair
his punctured spleen
was completely successful.
And now the orthopedic
team can take over."
"Oh, thank all the
gods," Bao Shou Yen
sighed, easing back in to
her seat for the first time.
"We've already lined up the
top reconstructive plastic
surgeon in London,
Dr. Peter Ashley,
and he'll be in
the operating room
alongside the orthopedic
team attending to your son."
"My poor boy," Bao Shou Yen
said, her eyes getting moist.
"Your son was very lucky."
"And the British girl?"
"The girl is still
in surgery, but I'm
sure she'll pull
through just fine,"
Eddie said, putting
on his peppiest smile.
Barely 30 minutes earlier, Eddie
had been on another airplane
parked in a private hangar at
Beijing Capital International
Airport, taking in the grim
details during a hastily
arranged crisis management
meeting with Mr. Tin,
the grey haired security
chief for the Bao family,
and Nigel Tomlinson,
his bank's Asia chief.
The two men had climbed
aboard the Lear jet
as soon as it had landed,
huddled over Nigel's laptop
while an associate
in London gave
the latest update via a
secure feed video conference.
"Carlton is out of surgery now.
He was quite a bit banged up.
But being in the driver's
seat with his air bag
and everything, he actually
suffered the least injuries.
But of the English
girl, it's touch and go.
She's still in a coma
and they've relieved
the swelling in the brain.
But that's all they
can do for her now."
"And the other girl?"
Mr. Tin asked, squinting at the
small, pixelated pop up window.
"Uh, we're told she
died on impact."
Nigel sighed.
"And she was Chinese?"
"We believe so, sir."
Eddie shook his head.
"What a mess.
We need to track
down the next of kin
immediately before they're
contacted by the authorities."
"How do you even fit three
people into a Ferrari?"
Nigel asked.
Mr. Tin twirled
his phone nervously
on the lacquered walnut console.
"Carlton Bao's father is
on a state visit to Canada
with the Premiere of China and
nothing must interrupt him.
My orders from Mrs. Bao
are that note of a scandal
must ever reach his ears.
He must never know
about the dead girl.
Do you understand?
There's too much at stake
given his political position.
And it is especially
sensitive with a big
once in a decade changeover
in party leadership happening
right now."
"Of course, of course,"
Nigel assured him.
"We will say that the white
girl was his girlfriend.
And as far as the
father is concerned
there was only one girl in the
car." "Why does Mr. Bao even
need to know about
the white girl?"
"Don't worry, Mr. Tin, I have
handled much worse dealings
with those [INAUDIBLE]
children in--" Eddie boasted.
Nigel shot Eddie
a warning glare.
The bank prided itself
on utmost discretion,
and here was his
associate blabbing
away about other clients.
"We have a tactical
response team in London
that I am personally directing.
And I can assure you we will
do everything to contain this,"
Nigel said before
turning to Eddie.
"How much do you
think it would take
to keep Fleet Street quiet?"
Eddie inhaled deeply trying
to do some quick calculations.
"It's not just the press.
The policeman, the ambulance
drivers, the hospital staff,
the families.
There's going to be an ass
load of people to shut up.
I would suggest 10 million
pounds for starters."
"Well, the minute you
land in London, you
need to take Mrs. Bao
straight to the office.
We need her to sign
off on a withdraw
before you take her to the
hospital to see her son.
I'm just wondering
what we should
say if Mr. Bao asks
why we needed so much,"
Nigel pondered.
"Just say the girl needed some
new organs," Mr. Tin suggested.
"We can also say that we need to
pay the boutique," Eddie added.
Those Jimmy shoes are
bloody pricey, you know?"
[APPLAUSE]
And that's basically
how book two begins.
HOST: Yeah.
That's great because
that leads exactly
in to my first question,
which is where do you
draw inspiration for your
characters and their antics
from?
Because I read about
a 2012 Ferrari crash
in Beijing involving two
young women and the son
of a high level
government official,
which sounds very strangely
similar to what you just read.
So I was wondering if
you're an avid reader
of the local Asian press.
KEVIN KWAN: I really am.
I get lots of Google alerts
on what's happening in China.
And it really was my
intention from the time
I started the first
books I had always
intended this to be a trilogy.
And I knew it would
start in Singapore
in sort of this
established Asian capital.
But I really wanted to move the
action in book two to China.
My original intention was to
call the next book "Crazier
Richer Asians."
And so naturally you have to go
to China and to the antics that
are happening there right
now and keep on happening.
HOST: Yeah.
That's great because
that leads right
to another question I have.
KEVIN KWAN: Oh, gosh.
This is being
videoed, by the way.
HOST: Yes.
So, yeah, I know you're
working on that third book.
And, like you said, the first
one took place in Singapore.
And then it went to
China to another level.
What is that third
crazier level?
Like where can it go from there?
KEVIN KWAN: You will
just have to see.
HOST: Oh.
KEVIN KWAN: But I really
hope to explore yet
another facet of Asia.
HOST: OK.
KEVIN KWAN: And really sort
of reveal some hidden truths
to that aspect of Asia.
HOST: Awesome.
Very cool.
So I know that you come from
a well off Singaporean family
yourself.
So I was wondering what
prompted you to write the book,
and why now?
KEVIN KWAN: What
prompted and why now.
Really it was because
maybe starting five
or six years ago
I would really see
all these headlines in
the "New York Times"
and the "Wall Street Journal"
and various other magazines,
"Forbes" magazine.
It was all about the Asian
miracle, economic miracle, Asia
isl booming.
So that would be one sort
of trope of literature.
And then there would
be these other articles
about the corruption of
China or the crazy spending
antics of Asians.
And I just felt that it was such
an unfair portrayal of what's
actually a much more complex
social economic issue that's
unfolding on the other
side of the world that's
sort of taking place.
And so I really wanted
to write this as a novel
and really tell a
more human story
of what it's truly
like to be living
in Asia from a family
of extreme wealth,
and what it's like to not be
from families of extreme wealth
also.
Because it's such an
interesting confluence
of events happening there.
HOST: Yeah.
That definitely is interesting.
And something else that I
thought was really interesting
is, of course, there's the
difference between old money
and new money, which we've seen
since the day of like F. Scott
Fitzgerald, but there's
another layer that you
add in your book
between the younger
generation of old money, and the
older generation of old money.
Like you see with Astrid and
Edison's love for couture,
versus their moms who would
stay six in an apartment
room instead of
paying for a hotel.
So I was wondering
if that's something
that you're seeing now.
Is it specific to China
and specific to Asia
and what exactly was
leading up to that?
KEVIN KWAN: It's something
I've seen all my life,
quite frankly.
And I think it's a very
typical human nature
thing for the first
generation to make the money,
and the second
generation to spend it,
and the third generation to
waste it all away in a way.
But especially in Asia
and in China right now,
the process of gentrification
and the process
of fortune making has
been so accelerated
in Singapore and Hong Kong,
it took families decades
to build up fortunes.
Sometimes whole generations
before the next generation
could benefit.
But in China we're seeing it
happen at warp speed, where
people are making overnight
fortunes, billions
of dollars over a decade.
An interesting statistic
that I just came across
was that 10 years ago there was
not even a single billionaire
in mainland China.
And today, as of last week,
there are 597 billionaires.
HOST: That's crazy.
KEVIN KWAN: They have
more billionaires
now than at Google.
Believe it or not.
No.
More than the United
States actually.
So they've surpassed the
US in billionaire creation
in the last decade.
And that's kind of crazy.
So you see the spending and
how it's changed the culture.
HOST: So I saw that the
President of China, Xi Jinping,
spoke out this year advising
the second generation
rich in his country to
think about the source
of their wealth and how to
behave after becoming affluent.
And some local governments
have taken steps
to re-educate their
wealthy elite.
And in June, according to
the "Beijing Youth Daily,"
70 heirs to major
Chinese companies
had to attend lectures
on filial piety
and the roles of traditional
values in business.
KEVIN KWAN: They went to wealth
concentration camps, basically.
A wealth re-education
camp, which
is interesting because
in the last few years
so much of their antics
they've been reporting it
on social media, and it
has been going viral.
There are a few famous cases.
I don't want to
mention the names.
But we all know
about the guy who
Instagram a picture of his
dog wearing two Apple Watches.
And another case of a very
famous media personality
that was just sort of
photographing piles of cash
on a bed.
It's been kind of crazy.
And it's really beginning to
trickle down and really affect
the general population
of China, who do not
have billions of
dollars and who are
angry at the entitlement
of that they see.
And so I think the
Chinese government really
is taking this seriously in
terms of this is the future.
This is the new
generation that's
going to be taking over
all these industries
and businesses.
And they need to kind
of learn the ropes.
HOST: In their wealth
concentration camps.
KEVIN KWAN: Yeah.
Exactly.
HOST: Are these kinds of
actions happening in Singapore?
Or is it very China specific?
KEVIN KWAN: It's
very China specific.
Because Singapore has a very
sort of established old money
sort of aristocracy
that's existed
for over a hundred years.
So they have learned their
own way over the decades
how to manage their money.
How to hide their money.
How to show their money.
It's a very different mode
of behavior than what's
happening in China now.
HOST: OK.
That makes sense.
And then speaking of the
crazy antics in China,
I know that you've
had to tone down
a lot of antics for your book
so it would be more believable.
And I was wondering if
you could indulge us
in something that
is real but you
had to take out of your book.
Or just another real
crazy situation.
KEVIN KWAN: So many things
I had to change or take out
to protect the identities
of people and places
I was able to gain
access to or invited to.
So I can't be too specific
about these instances.
But let's just say that so much
of what happens at this level
is becoming much and
much more hidden.
We're seeing now
these Chinese families
moving into really
safeguarding their privacy,
not wanting to overtly
show off what they have.
So I was able-- when
I was last in China--
I was able to see some
incredible, incredible
residences, for example.
How people live privately.
So there's a new
level of discretion.
How people spend their money--
it's becoming covert now,
which is interesting.
But it's unfathomable.
Their spending in the way that
the Vanderbilts were spending
at the turn of the century.
Building gigantic
pleasure palaces,
commissioning planes
from companies,
these gigantic planes.
HOST: Are there koy
ponds in planes?
That blew my mind.
KEVIN KWAN: The Koi
pond, I don't know.
I've seen and heard of other
planes with crazier stuff.
So the Koi pond was
a really tame version
of me being able
to say something
without identifying a plane.
Because there is this one
plane, which I did see,
which is so specific.
And what they managed to
accomplish on this plane
was sort of mind boggling.
It might involve bowling.
HOST: Wow.
How has your response been
from your Asian audiences?
And has that varied
country to country?
KEVIN KWAN: I think
uniformly there's been
a great deal of excitement.
It's certainly been
much more positive
than I was anticipating
it to be because I
do satirize this world.
But when I was on tour a
few months ago in Hong Kong
and the Philippines,
the response
was pretty much
overwhelmingly positive.
There's just so
much excitement I
think coming from
that part of the world
that the West is
paying attention now
and that we're
telling a story that's
contemporary about what's
really happening in Asia now
and portraying Asians
in a positive light,
generally speaking.
HOST: Exactly.
And in a different light than
they're used to being seen in.
KEVIN KWAN: Exactly.
HOST: Yeah, I felt like a
common motif in your book
is how Westerners
underestimate Asians,
whether it's through the opening
scene in the London hotel
in "Crazy Rich Asians," where
the families were discriminated
against because of their race,
or in "China Rich Girlfriend"
where the designers
had only sent them
runway looks
specifically tailored
to the Chinese market
instead of collections
that would be shown
in New York or Paris.
So I was wondering if
this was a reflection
of the general
underestimation of Asians
that you're seeing going
on in the world now.
KEVIN KWAN: Definitely.
And it's being
turned on its head.
Because, for example, if
you go to Europe now, even
in New York, most of the people
you see shopping at the top car
dealerships, at the top jewelry
stores on Madison Avenue
are distinctly Asian.
So the wealth
equation has shifted.
And luxury spending,
the Asian consumer
now accounts for 70% of
the global luxury market.
So all these companies
have to very quickly redo
their strategies
to respond to that.
HOST: That is crazy.
KEVIN KWAN: It's no
accident that four
of the top hotels in London
are owned by Singaporeans.
HOST: Oh, and then
speaking of Singaporeans.
I was wondering because this
is an area filled with Asians
from so many
different countries,
how would you describe how
different Singaporean culture
is to others?
I know you touched upon
in a little bit before.
KEVIN KWAN: I think Singapore is
interesting because it's always
been this crossroads
since the 1800's.
It was a port city.
It was sort of the deep border
port in the Southeast Asia
region.
So it really was kind of
the most multicultural city
in Asia, I feel.
With this Indian, Malaise,
Chinese, and European
population just co-mingling
and existing and supporting
each other very well.
And it's sort of advanced into
the 21st century with this very
multicultural city.
And it's really
created a dynamism
that's very different
than other cities in Asia
where, for example, Taiwan
is very much a Chinese city.
Hong Kong there's a
colonial British influence
that's still overwhelmingly the
population that's Cantonese.
Where then Singapore you have
all these groups and dialect
groups of Chinese,
mixing with Malaise,
with Indians, with Europeans,
now more than ever.
So it's made it a very sort
of cosmopolitan melting pot.
HOST: Got it.
And that's definitely
reflected in all the food
you mention as well in the book.
That makes sense.
KEVIN KWAN: Yeah.
It's the original foodie town.
HOST: Yeah.
It was probably one of the most
enjoyable parts of the books.
So I wanted to talk about
your upcoming movie.
So I love this quote from
you from June of this year
in the "Hollywood Reporter."
And I quote, "It's so perplexing
to see how casting in Hollywood
is so defensive.
I think audiences are much more
accepting of casting choices.
When "Crazy Rich
Asians" came out,
there was initial
interest from a producer
who wanted to change
the heroine, Rachel Chu,
into a white girl.
I tell that story to book clubs
in suburban middle America
and they go crazy.
Why does Hollywood
think we want to see
this movie with white people?
They don't need every
film to be chock
full of the latest stars."
So now that you're further
along in the film development
process, I was
wondering if you've
run into any difficulties
in casting an all Asian cast
or if that's something
that we're going to see.
KEVIN KWAN: We're not in
the casting process yet.
But I can tell you that the
producers, the financers,
everyone involved is
so excited to really
cast a pan Asian dream team
of actors from North America,
from all over Asia,
to really reflect
the diversity of
characters in my book.
And there hasn't been
even a suggestion
that anyone's not
going to be Asian.
You know, the book is
called "Crazy Rich Asians."
And I think not just
Hollywood, but everyone in Asia
is so fascinated by
this because it's
the first time it's happening.
And so everyone has
skin in the game.
They're all wanting to see
what happens, who is cast,
and there's tremendous pressure
for Hollywood to do this right,
and to really represent
this right in a way that's
never happened before.
HOST: Yeah, exactly.
KEVIN KWAN: But
definitely I think
Hollywood has made a lot
of very defensive moves
with their casting choices
in the past few years.
Like with "Aloha"
the Cameron Crowe
movie where a Hawaiian
Chinese character turned out
to be Emma Stone.
And Hollywood didn't
used to be like this.
If you think back to
the '50s and the '60s,
really vanguard actors.
Hispanic, Chinese, Egyptian.
Omar Sharif to Nancy Kwan.
They made stars and people
would go and see these movies.
And now all they want to do is
cast people that are already
bankable box office hits.
And it's kind of very much
like an Ostrich in the sand
mentality, I think,
when audiences really
want to see new people.
they.
Want to see these new stories.
Not everything can be a
Marvel comic re-enactment.
HOST: So, speaking
of audiences, who
do you see as your audience
for this new movie that's
coming up?
KEVIN KWAN: You
know, we're really
trying to target this
to a global audience.
Because I've seen
with my books--
my book now has been
translated in to 12 languages
internationally.
The Hebrew edition
just came out.
And everywhere I
go I meet readers
who are like, oh
my god, you need
to do Crazy Rich Pakistanis.
You know, I'm from Israel, but
my family is just like this.
You need to do Crazy Cheap Jews.
Everyone has found a way to sort
of relate to the characters.
And so why wouldn't they
want to see this movie
about these crazy rich Asians?
So we don't have one
demographic in mind.
We're hoping to
make everyone happy.
HOST: Very cool.
So what are you hoping the
audiences will take away
from this movie then?
KEVIN KWAN: I hope they'll just
laugh and have a good time.
But also really see the
multidimensionality of Asians
and what's happening
in Asia right now.
That it's not just all war torn
countries and desperate people
having to give
away their babies.
Things like that.
There's a new narrative.
And these stories
can now be told.
HOST: Yeah.
Exactly.
Yeah, I've heard
your books compared
a lot to either
Jane Austen novels,
or maybe even
"Gossip Girl" series.
So I was wondering, would
you compare them to that?
And what were your literary
inspirations for this?
KEVIN KWAN: I mean,
it's interesting.
I mean, Jane Austen is one
of my favorite writers.
And I do like a lot of these
writers like Edith Wharton
and F. Scott Fitzgerald
and Dominick Dunne
and people that were
writing about these circles
of privilege.
You know, I think since
the beginning of writing,
since the beginning of
literature, the general public
has always been fascinated by
the foibles of the very rich.
Machiavelli wrote "The Prince."
And then from then on it's
been trollop, and Jane Austen,
it always has been concerning
people of power and privilege.
And now that the power and
privilege has sort of shifted
to Asia, this is the new crowd.
These are the new Elizabeth
Bennets of the world.
HOST: Your book has
been well received
by many different audiences
regardless of their background.
So were there parts that you
saw maybe non-Asian audiences
weren't understanding as well?
Or was it something that
everyone could relate to?
KEVIN KWAN: I really
tried to make the story
as universal as possible.
And I wasn't trying to write
for an Asian specific audience.
If anything, I was
just trying to write
for a mass American
audience really.
And I have lots
of footnotes just
to add more detail to some
of the cultural nuances
of the story, and
things like that.
So hopefully it's
something that's
enjoyed and understandable
by everyone.
I did notice though
touring in Asia,
I was in the Philippines
for a couple of weeks.
And the Filipinos I think
are like my super fans.
I'd never seen this many
people turn out for readings,
and screaming women.
I now know how
Justin Bieber feels.
But I realized
something interesting
was that they're a very
westernized Asian culture.
They're part of Asia.
They get all the Asian jokes.
But they're also very
Americanized having
been an American territory.
So they're getting all the
jokes on every level, which
I think has made them
appreciate the book on a much
deeper level.
And I hope that in
book three I can really
achieve that so that everyone
can sort of enjoy it,
not just the Filipinos.
HOST: How has the reaction been
from your Chinese audiences
or your Singapore audiences
where a lot of the book
does take place in?
KEVIN KWAN: From what I've
heard, they've been thrilled.
The book has done really
well in Singapore.
And the Singaporeans I
hear from who like the book
are very happy about it.
There might be some people
who have been not as happy.
HOST: Yeah.
They probably don't tell you.
KEVIN KWAN: But they
don't say anything.
They're too polite.
But we'll see.
But it's been generally
extremely positive.
HOST: That's great.
What audience reaction has
surprised you the most?
KEVIN KWAN: Actually, from
Asian Americans and Asians
living in Western countries.
Asian Canadians,
Asian Australians.
I don't think Asian Americans
were the first people
to actually read the book.
I think there was some
skepticism at first.
You're confronted by a book
called "Crazy Rich Asians."
You kind of tend to go,
what's this all about?
HOST: Yeah.
It did take me awhile
to pick up the book.
I'm not going to lie.
KEVIN KWAN: Yeah.
But after it sort of entered
in to the mainstream media
and more and more people
started talking about it,
I think a lot of the
audience shifted.
And more and more I began seeing
it interacting with much more
Asian American audiences.
And for them, there's been
kind of a profound reaction
from some people.
They've told me how it's
the first time they've
seen themselves portrayed in
such an honest contemporary way
without all the issues
of previous generations.
So they feel very
kind of inspired
to read about characters who
are empowered, sexy, attractive,
normal people that just
happen to be Asian.
So that's been a really lovely
sort of fringe benefit, which
I never expected.
AUDIENCE: I find as
I'm reading your book,
my head is spinning with
all the inter-family webs
of who's involved with who
and how they know each other.
So did you build
these family trees
first and how they would
interweave and interact
with each other?
Or did that come as
you were writing?
KEVIN KWAN: I really
built it first.
I already had an idea of the
sort of very complex structure
of intermarried families.
And the family tree I think
was the first thing I did.
And then I said,
OK, this chapter
is going to tell the story.
This chapter I'm going
to tell that story.
And in that way I slowly
kind of put together
this jigsaw puzzle.
But it did start
with the family that
is in the first page
of "Crazy Rich Asians."
Thanks for asking a question.
AUDIENCE: I liked your
comment earlier about
how you felt like things like
the "Wall Street Journal"
on the "New York Times"
were unfairly portraying
these antics of
rich, young, Asians,
and so one thing I
was wondering was
what's the human side of these
wealthy sides of mainlanders?
What are their
particular struggles
that are different
from what we've
seen from other generations
of rich people in general?
KEVIN KWAN: I think that
because for so many of them
these cities and the way of
life has changed so completely
just in the last
10 years, they're
sort of struggling
to find themselves
in this hyper modern
world, first of all.
So I think there's a
lot disorientation.
There's been a lot
of displacement
from families being
moved from rural areas,
small towns, small villages,
into the big cities.
And so they're all
having to adapt
to living together
multi-generationaly
in these mega cities.
Number one.
And then number
two, specifically
for the privileged set
of people, a lot of them
are being educated in the West.
In fact, that's kind
of the goal for sort
of well-to-do Chinese family,
starting from middle class
on up, is you want to send
your kids to Harvard or Yale.
And these kids are getting
Western educations.
And then they're having
to go back and confront
the reality of China.
And, you know, the
traditions the cultures
and the expectations of their
parents, of their grandparents.
And there's a huge disconnect
between their new dreams
and aspirations and what their
country and their society
expects of them.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
what you were doing
before you wrote these books.
And you kind of
touched on the fact
that the news cycle
inspired you to write this.
But had you always
planned to be a novelist?
Were you a novelist?
Do you have other books that
I haven't been made aware of?
Just curious of your journey.
KEVIN KWAN: Thank you.
I was not a novelist
until three years ago.
My first degree was
in media studies
actually at the
University of Houston.
And so I always had this
dream after graduating
with this sort of
communications focused degree
to then get a design and
visual side of the degree
so I could meld those
two and become sort
of like this double threat
in this whole new world
of the internet and
the World Wide Web
and going into new media.
So that was originally
my intention.
But, you know, life changes.
And it takes you
along different ways.
So I went to design school, art
school, after my first degree
and found myself working for
a very influential design
firm in New York
afterwards-- M & Company.
And from there I
started getting drawn
into being a consultant to a lot
of different media companies.
So I've worked for Hearst.
I've worked for Conde Nast.
I've worked for design
firms, architectural firms,
I was part of helping TED.com
relaunch their website in 2008,
I think.
So I had this whole other side
in sort of design consulting.
So it wasn't until
2010 that I decided
I wanted to really
write a book like this.
I just kind of went
for it never expecting
it would lead to this.
Just something I was
doing as a hobby.
AUDIENCE: I am wondering
in regards to your movie.
Do you plan on sitting
on the dailies?
Did you ask for
partial cast approval?
How much creative control
did you relinquish?
KEVIN KWAN: I'm an executive
producer of the movie.
So I am as involved
as I want to be.
But I also recognize that
I'm not the expert here.
And I've put my trust in this
incredible team led by Nina
Jacobson at [INAUDIBLE].
And she's had an
amazing track record
of making greet books
into great movies.
And every author that
she's worked with
has so far been
really happy with her.
So I'm trying to
really kind of let
that movie team have the
freedom to sort of create this
without being that
control freak author.
Because at the end
of the day I realize
a movie is very
different from the book.
It will never be the book.
First of all, it's going
to be an hour 45 minutes.
You can't tell my story
in that length of time.
But hopefully it captures
the DNA of the book
and it's a fun ride for people.
That's my primary concern.
So will I be sitting on set?
I don't know.
We'll cross that
bridge when we need to.
But I'm really focused
on letting this movie
be what it wants to be.
AUDIENCE: I was really
curious about all the details
that you had about passion.
And I have to admit, it's
kind of over my head.
But how did you do
the research for that?
And you also mention
talking with people
in keeping their identities,
but at the same time,
are they cool with you giving
a lot of these cool details
about them?
KEVIN KWAN: I
think, first of all,
in most cases I've
changed the stories
and scenarios and
the details enough
to where no one's recognizable.
And, number two, there's
nothing malicious
about what I write about.
So hopefully people
aren't too upset,
even if they're
somewhat recognizable.
And then to answer
the first question,
as a creative and
design consultant,
it was kind of my business to do
trend forecasting, to be ahead
of the curve on fashion
trends, design trends,
things like that.
So that really
was a natural part
of bringing my experience
into writing that novel.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
airlines and everything.
Were you approached by any
big luxury brands in the movie
or like for the next book
or anything about like, hey,
you should mention
me because I'm
this awesome brand
that represents
what you're writing about.
KEVIN KWAN: I
haven't and I don't
think I'd ever do that because
I like having this editorial
independence to really kind of
craft the world I want to craft
and have the characters wear
what I think they should wear
versus having Chanel
endorse everything,
even though they're in the
book like eight million times
because the women wear Chanel.
It's an interesting
thought, but it's not
something I don't think I'd
ever want to be part of that.
For now, at least.
Movie might be a
different things.
But that's for the movie people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN KWAN: It's
interesting you say perfect,
because to me I
think Astrid is such
an interesting tragic character.
She has the beauty.
She has the style.
She has the breeding.
She has everything in the
world except happiness.
And [INAUDIBLE] keeps
getting into trouble
with his mother
and his grandmother
and all the various
crazies around him.
HOST: I always thought that
Rachel's portrayal was also
very perfect.
Or every time anyone
described her they're like,
she's so beautiful and perfect
and funny and smart and nice.
Yeah.
That was just my takeaway.
KEVIN KWAN: So
maybe in book three
I have to maker her
really trip up much more.
yeah.
Well, she had a lot
of blind spots, too.
HOST: That's true.
KEVIN KWAN: Wouldn't you say?
HOST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how would
you say the reception has
been for your second book
compared to your first book?
KEVIN KWAN: It's been
enormously positive.
I think the reviews
for the second book
actually for the most
part have been even better
than the first book.
And I hear from
different readers
that say, oh, we loved the
first book so much more.
But I also hear equally
from other readers
that say, oh, I loved the
second book so much more.
So it's been very evenly mixed.
I think a lot of people,
because of the first book
was to them so
different, there's
always a little more
affection for the first book
than for the second.
The second is less novel.
I don't know.
What do you think?
HOST: I find this with
all series of books
that it's hard to pick
one, because they're
all part of a larger story.
Like I always use Harry
Potter as an example.
I love every single book, but
they build upon one another
so you can't really take one out
of the equation as much for me.
KEVIN KWAN: Yeah.
And I'm really hoping
with the third book
to add yet another level
of dimensionality that sort
of contextualizes
book one and book two.
And people will
finally understand
why I did what I did
instead of just being angry.
There are not many angry people.
But there are a few
that would nitpick.
It's like, well, there's
a method to the madness.
You'll see.
HOST: Yeah.
Exactly.
In the end.
KEVIN KWAN: Believe
it or not, I've
met a lot of readers who
started with the second book
and have just
enjoyed it equally.
I can't imagine
how, having read it.
Because it really starts--
it's like a cliffhanger,
and then book two begins.
So that's how I would
recommend reading it.
It'll be a much more rich
experience in that way.
HOST: Yeah.
Because then you know
the characters better.
As soon as you
said Edison Cheng I
was like ha-ha, because I
know him from the first book
and you just know
how ridiculous he is.
KEVIN KWAN: And so
many people would
tweet me or they would just
say, oh my god, the minute
he came on page one and
said the famous words
he says, which I
censored for YouTube,
people would start laughing
the minute he utters
his trademark swear word.
HOST: Definitely.
And the same thing
with Katy [INAUDIBLE].
It's like as soon as she enters,
it's like, yes, she's back.
AUDIENCE: So I absolutely
love the series.
And I was wondering
when I will no longer
have to wait for the third
book and for the movie?
Do you have any sense of
when those will come out?
KEVIN KWAN: I mean,
don't hold me to it.
But I'm really hoping for 2017.
Because I have to write
the third book now.
And I'm still on tour.
So I'm really hoping after this,
this is really the end of tour,
to really buckle down, write
book three, and get it out.
I really want this to be over
with too as soon as possible.
HOST: Do you have people
suggesting like crazy things?
Like in book three
you should do this?
KEVIN KWAN: All the time.
All the time.
You have no idea.
On social media people
send me stories.
People try to cast
themselves in the next book.
I had this Indonesian tycoon
send me videos of his daughters
Sweet 16 birthday party.
They spent like $10
million on her Sweet 16.
It was out of control.
And he's like, you should
feature this in the next book.
Legally I can't feature
that anyone has sent to me.
HOST: Yeah.
OK.
What was one idea where you
heard it and you're like,
this is never going
to be in the book.
KEVIN KWAN: You're really
putting me on the spot.
I really can't think
of anything off hand.
There have been so many crazy
suggestions of what to do,
what not to do.
But I just try to
filter that out
and be true to the story
I always wanted to write.
AUDIENCE: Was there
an idea of that you
wish you could put in the book?
Something that somebody
said and you'd go,
wow, this is absolutely crazy.
KEVIN KWAN: It's interesting
because in book two
there's a racing sequence.
I don't know if you've
read the books yet.
Yeah.
It's now become a hobby
of the crazy rich Chinese
to have these drag races.
They don't do it in
China because they don't
want to be caught in China.
So they do it around the world.
They meet up in
California or Sydney.
They bring in their exotic cars
and they do these drag races.
And so I really structured
a whole couple of chapters
around these pivotal scenes.
And my editor was like, no way.
She's like, no one's
going to believe it.
I'm like, but it's
really happening.
I can show you the headlines.
I can show you the pictures.
But he's like,
there are things you
don't want to lose the reader
in the momentum of the story.
So I had to take out
most of that scene, which
maybe will find its way
in to the movie, too.
I don't know.
So there are certain
scenes I wish I could keep.
But for the sake
of believability
was told that it
was better to cut.
Thank you so much.
It's really a
pleasure to be here.
HOST: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]